depuis quelques mois les banques
centrales on voit des signaux de baisse
de taux de rachat d'actifs alors que
l'économie mondiale ralentit les
tensions commerciales suscite de
l'inquiétude des marchés financiers on
voit des signaux de récession avec nous
ce soir jean boivin directeur de
l'institut blackrock investment qui est
la plus grande firme d'investissement du
monde ancien sous-gouverneur à la banque
du canada bonsoir monsieur boivin et
soir monsieur fillion c'est un plaisir
de vous accueillir vous avez un long
curriculum vitae et tout un parcours
parce que vous avez été l'élève de
bengorine qui est l'ancien président de
la réserve fédérale aux états unis vous
avez été sous gouverneur à la banque du
canada sous ministre délégué aux
finances de talent ondres mais n'est ce
pas voyez absolument et vous surveillez
donc de près l'évolution des banques
centrales
on est dans un nouveau cadre en quelque
sorte c'est à dire un cadre économique
avec cette possible récession mais aussi
le président trump aux états unis qui
change un peu la donne
comment vous voyez des choses
présentement on est dans un
environnement
un peu sans précédent sous ces aspects
là les marchés se sont un peu comme les
enfants et ont tendance à focus et sur
une chose à la fois et est présentement
c'est vraiment les tensions
géopolitiques qui est commercial qui
sont là la tension va et qui sont selon
nous le facteur déterminant sur
l'évolution des marchés à court terme et
salin à ça génère des inquiétudes sur
des presque de récession on pense que
ces risques là sont assez contenue à ce
stade ci mais il ya une anxiété qui est
présente cette anxiété là aussi à temps
je pense qu'elle est alimentée par le
fait qu' on a nos relations entre les
gouvernements et les banques centrales
qui est différente
oui et ça s'il ya des questions aussi
sur quelle va être la réponse lorsqu'on
fera dans une récession et c'est une
grande question exactement et juste
avant d'arriver une proposition que vous
faites comment vous pensez que les
banques centrales doivent réagir
en ce moment je pense beaucoup à jérôme
powell et la réserve fédérale qui d'un
côté subit la pression d'un président
qui veut des taux à zéro c'est ce qu'il
a dit aujourd'hui et en même temps il
est là pour mener une politique
monétaire
donc on voit ralentissement global qui
est attribuable en partie à la haute
tension qui se matérialise en 2019 pour
la première fois ont un impact sur les
noms aux perspectives globales et dans
ce contexte là il ya effectivement une
nécessité à assouplir la politique
monétaire et on le vus déjà eu un pivot
estime significatif en 2019
on s'attend à des baises quelques
baisses additionnelles aux états unis
ceci dit les attentes des marchés sont
assez agressive en terme
d'assouplissement on s'attend à plus 100
points de base de plus point de
pourcentage
un point de pourcentage et c'est pas
clair qu une tensions commerciales et
les implications que cela que cela pour
l'économie mais nécessairement de la
baisse de des baisses de taux seront la
solution est donc on pense que on a
quelques baisses additionnelles mais
c'est peut-être pas autant ce que les
marchés s'attendent et ça va créer des
questions intéressantes le reste de
l'année avec un président des etats-unis
qui veut beaucoup de baisse de taux est
ce que vous pensez que ça influence la
banque centrale je pense que la fed
évolué
une institution et pas juste jérôme pas
wall qui est inquiétant qui est en poste
il ya toute une équipe une institution
et les sillons est encore ce qu'elle est
ce qu'elle était et ils doivent opérer
dans un contexte dans un cadre doivent
justifier leur décision en terme de ce
qui va arriver avec l'inflation et
autres et donc ça je pense que ça nous
donne une certaine protection
dans ce contexte et donc je suis
convaincu que les légions de la fed de
son son répondre à ce qu'il doive
répondre ceci dit ça soulève des
questions et lorsqu'on voit une baisse
de taux on a plus de dialogue la
discussion présentement est ce que
c'était vraiment nécessaire ou c'était
parce qu'il ya eu une une pression
politique laquelle à douter on se met à
douter donc je pense pas que le doute
est justifiée mais il ya effectivement
plus de gens qui se posent la question
est et on de bruit autour de ces
questions et donc vous êtes arrivé avec
une proposition cet été avec deux autres
ex dirigeants de banques centrales
notamment stanley fischer l'ancien
gouverneur de la banque d'israël et de
dans cette proposition vous dites qu'il
faut une coordination plus clair entre
les banques centrales et les
gouvernements parce que la pression
politique va devenir de plus en plus
grande
qu'est ce que vous proposez donc je
pense que la première chose à m claire
pour pour en arriver là c'est qu'on
pense que pas présentement mais
lorsqu'il y aura six à une récession ou
un ralentissement plus marqué la marge
de manoeuvre des banques centrales
incluant toute l'innovation qui a été
fait depuis la crise est plus ou moins
utilisés et donc le coffre à outils est
pas mal vide
côté banques monétaire ce manque
centrale et ça sonne à la question
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire de plus
ça sera pas en baissant les taux on sait
que les taux à court terme ont pas
beaucoup d espace les taux à long terme
sont déjà à des niveaux est en europe on
a plus de deux tiers des obligations qui
offre des taux négatifs il se fait payer
pour emprunter aux états unis en europe
et dans ce contexte là ça c'est un gros
canal de transmission de la politique
monétaire qui finalement terminé donc la
question c'est comment on arrive à
stimuler l'économie sans reposer sur une
baisse de taux est propre à l'est
tellement plus bas et là c'est là qu'on
arrive à une coordination plus
importante
donc faut d'urgence même nom va essayer
de suggérer pour rendre ça plus concret
un exemple d'un fonds d'urgence de la
façon que ça pourrait être mise en place
mais l'idée principale c'est qu'on doit
avoir une façon d'aller plus directement
stimuler l'économie en mettant de
l'argent dans les mains de ceux qui
peuvent la déployer de façon plus active
sans avoir posé sur un incitatif de
baisse de taux c'est un peu ce que les
gouvernements fondé des fonds d'urgence
pour stimuler mais vous pensez que la
banque centrale pourrait agir plus
rapidement qu'un gouvernement
on a eu des exemples dans de gestion de
crise de fonds ici le fils d'un fonds
qui qui devrait être qu'il serait bien à
l'avancé en place est un élément d
assouplissement quantitatif qu'on a vu
en place mais ça irait plus loin dans la
mesure où c'est pas simplement acheter
des actions de compagnies ou avait
pardon des obligations gouvernementales
mais ça pourrait être des des mesures
qui ressemble plus à des politiques
fiscales en pratique et ça c'est pour ça
que ça donne un aspect de politique
monétaire un aspect de politique
budgétaire et que ça soulève des
questions importantes sur la façon de
gérer
monsieur boivin en mai dernier bloomberg
disait il ya deux grands candidats pour
succéder stephen poloz comme gouverneur
de la banque du canada car les nouvelles
hawkins qu'il a su gouverneur à ce
moment et vous ça vous intéresse
c'est toujours flatteur de faire partie
des discussions
je partirai peut-être commencer la
conversation le contexte dans lequel des
banques centrales et évoluent ils vont
évoluer il va être très difficile à
venir donc c'est un grand défi la seule
chose c'est que c'est pas nécessairement
les autres nombreux qui va déterminer la
liste s'est il ya un processus au canada
et je pense qu'une chose qui est
rassurante sait qu'on va passer sur les
courts eux je suis convaincu que dans la
liste va contenir des candidats de
qualité et on est chanceux de pouvoir
compter là dessus au canada donc vous
avez pris votre décision vous moi je
suis dans un rôle où je n'aime pas je
suis passionnée et puis une chose qu'on
m'a toujours dit c'est qu'on n'accepte
pas ou refuse pas un rôle qui n'a pas
été présentée et voilà c'est votre
réponse merci beaucoup monsieur boivin
au plaisir merci à vous merci bien